hello and welcome everybody to george pi
data global 2021 my name is zachary
i'm very happy to be here and be your
host of this session chris if you feel
comfortable to individual rename your
cell to a name you would like to be
quoted in this session
would be lovely if you could also add
your pronouns in there if any chance i
pronounce your name incorrectly please
correct me at any time please note we
are recording this session
[Music]
okay
i would like to welcome
barry to our session here we will talk
about
um the risk and skill running a large
investment risk system and how risk
analysis technique can help you
and
barry
needing a number of team within a manned
our technology team and main group man
group is at large have fun investing in
very wide range of asset and investment
style and now we are passing the time to
vary thank you
thanks zac uh let me just share my
presentation
hi everyone um
so i'm barry fitzgerald
uh
as zach said i i lead a few teams at mad
alpha technology team we're the part of
man group who looks after
trading decision making so the kind of
technology that helps
systems or people make their trading
decisions
i'm going to talk a little bit today
about what finance people mean when they
talk about risk
i'm going to talk a bit about uh
specific ways of quantifying market risk
and i'm also going to talk about some
other technologies in implementing
those techniques um
but let's let's just start with uh
what is risk so there's lots of types of
risk does the risk a meteorite might uh
hit a data center there's a risk you
might get injured in an automobile
accident et cetera the type of risk i'm
talking about today is market risk so
essentially the risk you might lose
money due to market events prices going
up or down et cetera
and the way i'm going to start looking
at this is with this graph
i have uh
three investments here so the top one is
an investment in bitcoin over the last
two years uh the
middle one is an investment in apple and
the bottom one which looks like and
actually is essentially just putting
your money in the bank
uh over the two years
and it's a question i'd often ask at
interview stage for someone working uh
in risk technology is uh which of these
investments is is riskier than the
others um and then how would you
quantify that and people can intuitively
nearly always answer the first like they
can tell me bitcoin is is probably more
risky than apple which is in turn
probably
more risky than just putting your money
in the bank
uh but but often struggle to quantify it
so i'm going to uh
use some examples from the domain we're
more familiar with to uh to try and
explain that
so
what exactly is market risk well one one
way is a good way to think about it is
how much money might my investment is
tomorrow
you might have made or lost lots of
money in the past with your investment
or you might be brand new to an
investment
but
on each day you should be comfortable
you know if you can answer this question
you can then decide if you're
comfortable with that potential loss
like and if you're not comfortable with
it maybe you reduce the size of your
investment or you you take hedging
trades or something like that but that's
why it's useful you if you get an idea
of the answers in this question you can
you can make decisions that affect that
future
so
let's
move now just to a slightly different
domain but i think will help explain how
we measure risk and finance so i have
two databases here i've just simulated
this but uh request times and individual
requests and it's a very kind of easy
answer for us as people working at
technology which database would you
would you prefer to use the one on the
left has a nice tight
uh spread of request times whereas the
one on the right has requests spiking up
you know to over 20 seconds
we could make this even easier to answer
by transforming it to histogram so if we
take all of the request times and plot
another histogram again now this makes
it like really super obvious we can see
the one on the left has a nice tight
distribution of request times
whereas the one on the right has this
long tail we can see like an individual
request took 25 seconds
and it makes it very easy to choose
between the two of these um but a
downside of looking at it like this is
this works extremely well if we're
comparing two databases but if we had
let's say 20 databases and 20 query
types on on each
just the space constraints and
interpretation if we were going to show
you know hundreds of these types of
charts it becomes lost in the noise
so there's always a desire but in kind
of performance
management and monitoring and and in
financial risk to to narrow this down to
can you know can we get a kind of a
a summary number that we can just you
know display a lot of numbers on a
single page we can have a table of
numbers for 20 databases very easily
and so to do that then
we start looking at percentiles and this
is a very common technique in in
monitoring we look we can we can say
50 of uh requests take longer than 10
seconds
one percent of requests take longer than
20 seconds uh
just from those two numbers you can
identify 20 databases i could very
quickly start identifying you know which
databases were slow which were faster
at times i may need to delve into the
detail of looking at the distribution if
i really wanted to diagnose things but
as a summary status
this is super useful
we want to do something similar for
financial risk and we can do a very
uh similar approach to this uh for
finance
so for example using my chart at the top
if we if we took the returns of bitcoin
and we took daily percentage returns and
formed the histogram of those
we could uh then choose a point on that
distribution and say
we have a one percent chance of losing
more than
x percent sorry y percent or y dollars
tomorrow so by using this like by
assuming tomorrow's returns will follow
a similar distribution to the historic
returns we can uh
we can get a good estimate of what we
might use tomorrow and that's a very you
know if we did that in turn for bitcoin
apple and um
our investment in in just putting our
money in the bank we would we would see
very different numbers it would it would
be a very easy way to quantify the risk
of those investments
but this is widely used across the
industry it's actually in some
regulations you have to use this uh i
have to at least have looked at this um
and it
has lots of advantages it's it's
computationally very efficient
it's quite easy to calculate it's very
interpretable if you tell someone you
have a one percent chance of
losing 10 tomorrow you can actually show
them well on these days in the past if
something similar happened you would
lose this much uh of your portfolio uh
so there's no fancy maths it's all very
interpretable
but there's lots of problems with it too
and i'll discuss some of those
so i think our this is fine dog
illustrates one of the problems here
that that
the past history of something happening
it doesn't necessarily mean it's not
going to happen tomorrow
a really good example of this is is
companies we know companies go bust and
go out of existence all the time
but for a company we've invested in by
definition
it still exists so even though we know
there is some chance of it going bust
tomorrow
that won't be represented by our
historical value at risk model and and
that's a problem that that we want to
fix
uh also
you only have a limited number of data
points there have only been so many
points in uh daily returns in the past
bitcoin has only
existed for so many years
uh and then also the returns for five
years ago in bitcoin might be have very
different properties to know so there's
lots of lots of issues with this
approach so it's still very useful but
there's some issues that
that can be improved upon
so
one way of doing this
is quite standard like you would fit
your historic returns to a normal
distribution then calculating the mean
and standard deviation you can start uh
calculating you know analytically what
the percentile chance of things are i
think you know at the moment we have 126
people in in this uh
uh video conference
if i if i took everyone's height and
fitted it to a normal distribution i
could come up with a pretty good
estimate of what are the chances of a
seven foot person being the next person
joining this conference
and that's even if we have no one who is
seven first in the in the talk at the
moment so it it allows us to make
predictions of things that haven't
happened yet in quite an accurate way
again this is widely used very widely
used very understandable there's a
little bit more maths rather than the
historic
value at risk but it it is quite often
used as well but in turn there's
problems with this approach so let's
think about some of those
so
market return distributions are not
normal um there have been cases in the
recent past of
seeing
180 standard deviation moves in in a
market that shouldn't happen in the
lifetime of the universe if a
distribution was normal and it happens
maybe not 180
standard deviations but large standard
deviation moves happen a lot more often
than a normal distribution would suggest
different assets are very different
return distributions um so investing
like an insurance or or a bond will have
very different to an equity return
distribution
um
and then also we tend not to invest in
single instruments we invest across
lots of different securities and lots of
different stocks and your pension would
be invested in many individual stocks
they aren't independent when the price
of oil moves the price of airlines also
moves
possibly in an opposite direction
those correlations change over time the
distributions themselves change over
time so
combining all of those to come up with
like a single distribution that
describes your total portfolios returns
is uh it's extremely hard and
not really mathematically or practical
uh to do so
so
it's not to say we do use normal
distributions and normal distributions
are used for certain cases but uh when
you're looking at extreme tail events
they they tend to be quite poor at that
and then there are just
computational issues with combining lots
of
distributions too
so what do we do next uh so there's
multi-failure analysis so i'll i'll do a
brief aside to talk about what
multi-color analysis is and and how it
can help in this scenario
so
personal story i was once trapped on a
desert island
and uh
a genie came along and told me that he'd
free me from the desert island if i
could give him the first 10 digits of pi
i know i hadn't memorized one of these
nice mnemonics for
the first 10 digits
uh obviously this isn't a true story but
imagine if we had to do this with no
with no tools no title no laptop what
would you do so one way of solving this
with monte carlo analysis
is to draw in the sand a square and
within that a circle
and then you could start throwing yeah
stones at that square and counting up
how many have landed inside the circle
uh and getting the ratio of that to the
ones that uh and within the square if
you missed the square altogether you can
just ignore that so
um
this is this will give quite depending
on how many stones you throw this will
give quite an accurate estimate of pi
and i think as you know this is a
data conference we can all tell this
this is the type of uh algorithm that
computers are extremely good at we can
we can sample millions or billions of
simulated stone flows and and calculate
it and then also
we can we can estimate how accurate up
to this point our estimate of pi is
so we can decide do we throw more stones
do we throw less stones depending on the
use case
the real power of this is
this works with an extremely limited
knowledge of pi i have new there's no
fancy maths here it's like you know the
derivation of that is is very trivial um
and
but still it can lead to quite an
accurate estimate of pi and this can be
used across a number of different
domains if you have
a vague
uh view of what the what the
distribution of results are
you can use monte carlo analysis without
describing it mathematically to get a
good estimate so
it is used in lots of other domains so i
think fog bugs for example uses it to do
project estimation or task estimation if
you have some data set on how long tasks
have taken in the past
you could uh
you could form a distribution from that
and then use monte carlo something to
see
how much could you expect you know an
outlier project to take in the future
even further example i gave up database
requests
if there is some absolute hard limit you
can never preach you could use monte
carlo analysis to say well how likely is
that it you may never have had a single
database query
uh of a particular type take longer than
an hour for example
but using monte carlo analysis you could
you could potentially start to look at
the what's the probability of tomorrow
one actually taking an hour so
it's a very useful technique because it
it
it makes no assumptions really about the
underlying math
of what you're trying to estimate
so how does this apply to finance
so what we do is we take historic
returns and the correlations of those
returns and
uh some random seeding transform those
into like random distributions for each
asset
uh there's definitely complexity there
that the random distributions have to be
related according to the correlations so
there is some quite fancy maths in
getting that to work
but then from that we can
we can form
essentially a big list of hypothetical
days like on the first row there on this
hypothetical day we believe asset one
will go up one percent two down five
percent and that's a tree
uh up two percent
and we know from our correlations in the
historic return turns that's a
believable day it is something we think
could happen
if we do that
uh hundreds thousands tens of thousands
millions of times we can uh we can start
forming a distribution for our overall
portfolio and
pick out a point on the distribution and
estimate the
uh
the value at risk so we would say like
the var 99 so the 99th percentile uh
last would be
one percent 2 10 depending on the
portfolio
so
this is widely used uh
somewhat a gold standard for complex uh
portfolios especially as you get into
mixed asset classes and so on
um
widely used across the industry there's
lots of challenges calculating data and
especially
it can be challenging uh it requires
quite a lot of infrastructure to put
this in place so i'm going to talk a
little bit about
that so some of the challenger
i'm always allowed to say big data no
matter how much data you say these days
someone will tell you it's not big data
such and such is big data
but in this case there are quite large
quantities of data we also need to do
many many simulations to get kind of an
accurate view
of the risk so exactly like going back
to my example it's like you need a lot
of stone shows before you start getting
you know you start smoothing out the
random effects
um
there's lots of like any big big data or
data science tasks a lot of the work is
engaging the data
looking at the conventions of the data
how's it been scaled has it had effects
applied or not applied all that that
kind of stuff
in common to kind of any of these
uh data tasks
uh
some of the steps are extremely cpu
intensive so they need to be uh
you know there's a there's a kind of a
scaling problem there
and some of them scale quite poorly with
number of assets like so some of the
aspects of its scale kind of in an
n-cubed way which which makes i think
asset classes difficult at times there's
ways around it but
it's a challenge there and then the last
one the non-additive results you can't
do this at the kind of an individual
level and just add it up all at the end
you uh
you essentially have to there's parts of
it you can do individually but the final
answer of what my myvar is you can't do
for portions of a portfolio and add it
up because
parts of the portfolio might be
correlated they might contribute to each
other and so on so it isn't the typical
store at all in the data warehouse and
then added up a type problem
so what about the technology we uh
use for this uh this is kind of a
slightly simplified uh
version of the kind of workflow we use
everything's like predominantly in
python
starts off with kind of a typical etl
job where we we get positions and
third-party market returns and so from
data vendors and from in other internal
systems
from that we form a
graph of calculations to calculate the
ingredients that we need for value at
risk so
that's like the correlation matrix and
then the simulated returns and p l
vectors of profit and loss vectors
from that in turn then we can calculate
that we we run a calculation engine on
top of that uh that combines those
ingredients to give us the answers we
want and then we serve it up to the the
users we still have quite a lot of pdfs
it's quite hard i'll talk about just a
little bit it's quite hard to get rid of
pdfs
um
people really like them even though it's
kind of an old technology but i guess
they they're quite simple to produce for
us but uh
i have some downsides too uh more and
more we're moving to kind of interactive
tools tools on people's mobiles mostly
web apps for this
and a growing thing that we're happy to
to serve is
more often than ever now people are
asking for python apis they don't trust
nice formatting or they don't trust a
nicely formatted report they
they say please just give me the data
give me an api to the data and then
they'll play it play with it to
themselves in python and that definitely
builds up a level of trust and it's also
definitely lower cost to produce than
creating interactive tools or
offensively formatted reports so it's
something we're happy to do i'll talk
about some of the other technology
choices uh
over the next few slides
but
most of this is in python obviously with
numpy and c where needed
uh and pandas and so on uh but it's
predominantly uh a python shop obviously
at the front end which react and uh
typescript there
so uh just some of the choices we've
made
uh we use airflow as a workflow engine
it started off as a cron replacement for
us but now we we do make use a lot of
its
tools for
uh directive graphs
it has a very nice gui has a large range
of integrations
it does have some magic it's quite
complex i think a good sign is it's
tending towards simplicity like the
version two of it is actually simpler
than version one which is a good trend
to have
i think overall this airflow's a net
plus and i would i would happily
recommend it to anyone
i think the space is quite immature
though that airflow kind of set a new
benchmark for these type of tools and
now some competitors are starting their
words like things like patchy term
prefects
etc uh so it'll be an interesting space
i think to watch over the next few years
to see
will something new come along that that
is better again than airflow but uh
overall definitely worth looking at for
these kind of
uh big uh batch processes
uh arctic uh full disclaimer here uh
arctic is a data store that was written
and open sourced by mam group so where
this isn't a
unbiased opinion here but if i say
it's a very fast data
store for time series and data frames uh
very easy to use
it like it's uh very fit to our needs
for financial data and so on but equally
applicable from i think most kind of
data frame storage use cases uh it's on
our github have a look at it we've done
a lot of work on it internally recently
as well so i'd recommend anyone to have
uh
have a look at it on github and also
watch the space for announcements uh
there could be a new version coming soon
and then next jupiter hub um i guess
everyone here probably has heard of
jupiter hell but i think i'm just a
slightly different spin on this that has
surprised me
we made jupiter hub available at man
under
you know a weblink python
its usage has astounded me it's used in
hr now it's used in compliance and legal
in sales
everywhere it
i think there is a real demand from
users and non-traditional users that if
you provide these tools they can make
use of it they can
gain efficiencies for themselves with
with these tools
um
and it has only been a net positive for
us it's led to us running more python
internal training courses and running
them not just for technologists and
people working on kind of quantity
aspects of it but for
literally everyone in the firm and we
quite strongly now say
at some point in the near future we
expect every employee at man regardless
of where they work will probably be
using python and will we get to the
quite that hundred percent probably not
but i think it's it's a very good goal
to have and it it uh we're definitely
seeing huge benefits for that so i'd
urge you if you
in your organization really think
outside the
traditional use cases of technology and
uh and python and data science people
will find a use for these tools it's
like
excel on steroids i think people have
described python pandas you know which i
think
if you work in one of these environments
where they've been using excel for
everything for many years
that's uh that's quite high praise
the next one i'll talk about is click
house so
some aspects of value at risk aren't
additive we do have lots of additive
stuff as well
so if you need very very fast olap style
querying over billions of rows click
house can really be a game changer in
our experience it's allowed us to build
web tools that look over
huge quantities of data billions of rows
with you know hundreds and low thousands
of columns
uh and do aggregations fast enough for
interactive use like so in many cases
sub second query times
we haven't there's lots of there's a
huge feature set we haven't pushed on
the features uh
but uh there's definitely potential for
future use there and
at the moment where
our needs have been solved by
single node deployments on kubernetes so
we haven't kind of investigated the
clustering story and so on
but
i would say
this is a real case of
if your use case fits into this kind of
niche
click house is definitely something
that's worth looking at it's it's been
quite powerful for us
what's next for us
uh we're looking to start moving off
some legacy technology some stuff not
shown on the diagram it's always easier
to turn on new systems and switch off
old things um so
there's always that aspect of the work
there's uh a move to gpus are there
aspects of this pipeline separate gpu uh
usage would uh
would help a lot
uh
does it move to cloud uh and how can we
use uh cloud more mostly we run this
internally because pros and cons of
cloud but it's something we want to
investigate a bit more
i mentioned it a little bit but the move
away from pdfs to more interactive tools
also
and then
this kind of explosion of the use of
python has also
started making us think more about if
we're writing apis we really need to
think about the developer experience as
well how do you write an api that's very
easy for
someone who isn't a full-time
technologist to use that it works as
expected so and so it's kind of like
developer experience rather than the
kind of more traditional user experience
with websites and so on hi barry just
wanted that you know we have five minute
left we want to take any questions from
the audience
uh yeah so good timing so
next time yeah
i'm happy okay
he got a question from germany um he's
acting asking how do you do that
transformation of israel return plus
correlation to random distribution
what's the point of creating those
random distribution
it's with some quite fancy maths i'm not
sure how to explain this uh on a zoom
call but i can i can point you some
maybe afterwards in slack i can put you
some directions so
um
you start with random numbers you
transform them into normal distributions
you apply the correlation structure on
top of that and then we transform the
distributions into something that's more
representative of the
market return so we essentially fatten
the tails and add skew to them
uh
there's there's various uh mathematical
steps
to go there that's actually the part
that's very cpu intensive and quite hard
to paralyze as well uh but i can
definitely point you in on slack
afterwards to some of the
some books that describe that process
okay another
question is in the chat room
um
they are asking who is the end user of
those products do any of those come to
the current directly or it is used as a
recommendation
for stock or asset to buy
okay yes i see that
so
a large amount of use of this is
internal use so far the risk team
themselves who has oversight across our
investments at man group for the
portfolio managers who are making the
investment decisions and then some of it
does go to the clients directly um is it
a recommendation of stocks and assets to
buy
a lot of it is after the fact of buying
things where you you use this type of
information to say this is your current
portfolio this is the risk
sometimes we do also use it in a
hypothetical way so
i have this portfolio i'm thinking about
trading this because whether that's a
system deciding that or that's a person
deciding that and then we would we would
run these risk numbers on this new
hypothetical portfolio
and that may inform the decision whether
or not to buy that
okay so manufacturer in the tripod and q
and a's and one more question is
what rome percent of your work is for
compliant version what percent is to
work driving profit or value
um
i
would say
good question i would say a very high
amount is towards driving profit and
values
um
we do definitely have regulatory limits
and compliance limits we tend to try
stay far away from those so it is more
of a discussion of like
uh
where
you know
are we taking risks in areas where we
think we will we have an edge or
we think we can add value and are there
risks we're taking that aren't
intentional so for an example of that it
might be
we have different investment teams if
they all invested in oil that might mean
that overall we have more of a risk in
oil than we we intend and so these
resistance would inform that and then we
could take action on that
okay our time is over could you
kind of move to the discussion this net
or get a time
and very thank you so much for talk and
being part of the party
global 2021 thank you so much
thank you everyone